Welcome to the lesson on Feature Selection.
I think Albert Einstein probably said it best when he said you
should make everything as simple as possible, but no simpler.
This is the idea behind feature selection, that you want to have
the minimal number of features that it takes to really capture the trends and
the patterns in your data.
Your machine learning algorithm is only going to be as good as the features that
you put into it.
So this is a place where you should really put some time and
attention as a machine learner.
There are two major things that are involved here.
The first is that you should have a way to select the best features that
are available to you.
In other words getting rid of the stuff that doesn't help you very much.
On the other hand there will be hopefully patterns in your data that you
need to draw out, and so potentially adding new features can
be ways that you can use your human intuition to access those patterns.
We'll go through both of these examples in this lesson.